mr. Stevens could I ask you just one
question of all the pictures that you
directed could you say which is your
favorite would you answer one little
question first yes yes I'd be delighted
of all the directors that you have
worked with which one is your favorite
okay I see what you mean question
withdrawn the truth is in each picture I
made there are many things I've liked
about it and many things I wish we could
done debt yes and I nobody who makes
films could possibly argue with you and
uncertain that the gentleman nominated
here this year for the best achievement
in directing the same way they are Bob
Fosse for cabinet John Boorman for
deliverance Yount Rowell for the
immigrants Francis Ford Coppola for the
Godfather Joseph mankiewicz for sloop
and the winner is Oh mr. Stevens I know
this will mean much more to the winner
if you open it won't you please I can
hardly believe that I think you do and
the winner is Bob Fosse Patera
thank you very much thank you
I must say I feel a little like Clint
Eastwood that you're letting me stand up
here because a couple or mankiewicz
hasn't shown up yet but being
characteristically a pessimist and cynic
this and some of the other nice things
that have happened to me the last couple
days may turn me into some sort of
hopeful optimist and ruined my whole
life there's there's so many people to
thank you've heard a lot of the names
but it's important for me to say them
and I'm sure I'm going to miss some of
the ones and regret it tomorrow
of course Liza and Joel Michael York
Marisa Berenson Marty Baum
Manny wolf Kander and ebb a terrific
government of Doug green a dear friend
of mine by name at Gwen Verdon and I'd
also like to mention sy here the
producer with whom I had a lot of
disputes but on a night like this you
start having affection for everybody
thank you